Okay, good morning. So,
today we are doing the Holy Roman
Empire.
Now, last class we did the Byzantine
Empire, which is considered the
continuation
of the Roman Empire in Eastern Europe.
The Holy Roman Empire is considered the
continuation
of the Roman Empire in Western Europe.
So,
the
um when we think about the Holy Roman
Empire in the West, we think of the
famous Voltaire
quotation about the Holy Roman Empire.
Voltaire is um a very famous French
Enlightenment thinker. We will talk
about Voltaire when we get to the
Enlightenment. What he said was the Holy
Roman Empire was in no way holy, nor
Roman, nor an empire.
And this sounds funny,
um and a lot of historians thought it
was a joke. But what I will show you
this class is actually this is very
true.
Okay?
So,
um the Holy Roman Empire was started in
the year 800,
um when
the Frankish king Charlemagne was
crowned Holy Roman Emperor by Pope Leo
the third in Rome.
Okay? And this marked a turning point in
Western history because this is really
the first time
that the Pope could anoint a monarch.
Before it was the emperor who anointed
the Pope. Now it's the reverse. And this
shows the supremacy of the Catholic
Church.
Historians have debated for a long time
why Charlemagne would agree to such an
arrangement.
And so, this is the topic we will we
will examine
this class. What motivated Charlemagne
to agree to agree to such a deal, and
what gave the Catholic Church Sorry,
what gave the Catholic Church so so much
power and prestige that they were
allowed that they had the power to
anoint emperors? Okay? So, that's the
topic we're looking at today. All right.
So, let's first look at Charlemagne's
motivations. Charlemagne,
um his name means Charles the Great, and
he is of the Frankish
Empire. And he was able to unite most of
Europe um through major innovations in
the military. Um so, he was the first to
introduce the idea of armored knights,
which became the standard military
doctrine and practice in Europe for
centuries. And
the idea of the knight would also pave
the way for feudalism in Europe. And
these are topics we'll discuss later on
uh in the class, okay? In this semester.
Um
what
Charlemagne is most celebrated for
um
uh is the fact that he started something
called the Carolingian Renaissance. Car-
Carolingian is the name of of his
family, and the Renaissance is this um
period of peace and prosperity in
Europe. Um
and he's most famous for the building of
cathedrals. He built 14 of them. This is
the most famous. It's called the Aachen
Cathedral in Aachen, Germany. You can
Guys, you can still go visit it, okay?
It is beautiful. Um the cathedrals of
medieval Europe are really the pyramids,
like the pyramids. They are meant to
give people a sense of awe and unity.
Uh the cathedral was meant to bring
heaven onto
uh Earth.
One really amazing aspect about the
cathedrals are their acoustics, the
sounds within
uh the buildings.
It is designed in a way that when the
priest speaks, his voice is projected
all around the cathedral, and the walls
bounce the um
voice back. And so, the parishioners,
the people who listen to the priest,
they feel they're surrounded by the
voice of God, okay? The vo- the the
voice literally enters you and makes you
feel transcendent. It makes you feel you
are moving towards heaven, that you are
approaching God.
All right? And these buildings are still
around. So, you can actually go and uh
visit them. This is a picture of
modern-day
uh Aachen, Germany, where people go
where tourists go and visit the
cathedral.
Okay? So, these buildings were designed
to be eternal.
Okay.
So,
um before I talk about Charlemagne and
why he chose to be crowned Holy Roman
Emperor, I need to give you a little bit
background about the geography of
Europe.
Now,
if we if we look at the
um
four major civilization empires of early
human history,
uh mainly Egypt, Mesopotamia, Indus
Valley, and China, we will discover that
there are three major similarities
among all four.
Okay? The first, as you can see from
this picture, is
two latitude only, okay?
They are in the same place.
They all benefit from temperate climate,
which allows for year-long agriculture.
That's the first major similarity.
The second major similarity is these are
all river civilizations, meaning they at
the center is a major river
surrounded by flat lands that allows for
the production of agriculture.
All right? So, in Egypt, there's the
Nile. In Mesopotamia, there are two
rivers, the Tigris and Euphrates. Indus
Valley Civilization is obviously Indus
River. And in China, there are two
rivers, right? There's the Yellow River,
and then there's the
uh Yangtze, okay? The Chang Jiang.
All right? And the third major
characteristic
um that's very important is they're
surrounded by natural boundaries,
whether it's mountains or deserts or
oceans or seas, okay?
And from this map, you can see very
clearly uh these three characteristics
for Egypt, right? Egypt has the Nile
surrounded by natural boundaries. The
desert is the Sahara Desert to the west,
these mountains um then protect
uh
Egypt. And that's what allows unity to
take hold very quickly in these
civilizations,
and what allows uh this civilization
to defend against outside invaders,
okay?
The same is true in China, obviously,
right?
Okay?
Um surrounded by mountains to the south,
to the west, and to the north, and then
the sea, okay? So, for most of of its
history, China was protected from
outside invaders.
This is all especially true in
humanity's greatest empire called the
United States. All right? So, if you
look at the United States, it is
a fortress, basically. It's protected by
two oceans and then mountains. But when
we within the United States, it's
serviced by the Mississippi River,
which allows for agricultural surplus,
and which allows for trade and
communication within the United States.
So, very early on, the United States
could become very wealthy as well as
unified.
And it did not have to fear external
enemies, and therefore it could prosper
without worrying too much about um its
national defense.
Okay, this is very important because
none of these three things are true for
the European continent, okay? Especially
Western Europe. Um it's much too uh
uh north, um and it's surrounded by lots
and lots of mountains. It also has no
major rivers.
Okay? So, as you can see from this map,
in Southern uh Western Europe, it's
mainly mountains, and to the north,
there are
um flat lands, but they're usually
covered by forests.
Okay? So, for most of its history,
Europe was divided and poor, and
um isolated from the rest of the world.
Okay?
The other thing about Europe that made
it distinct from the other civilizations
is within Europe, there are lots of
natural boundaries, and that's why
Europe remained divided for such a long
time. It was extremely hard to unite
Europe. Please remember, the Rome was
not a European empire. It was a
Mediterranean Empire. That's a huge
difference, okay?
So,
throughout most of its history, Europe
was divided into different fiefdoms. And
the prince the princes, the kings had a
complete authority over their kingdom.
It was very hard to compel them to
um listen to your authority. Charlemagne
had at at at that time the greatest army
in Europe, but even then, he was still
compelled to uh cooperate
with the other kings.
Okay?
So, he achieved a lot of what he did
through
conquest,
but he also achieved a lot of what he
did through alliances and treaties
and friendships and marriages, okay?
So, what this means is
if you want a unified Europe, you cannot
do so through military conquest. You
have to do do so through the idea of
legitimacy.
People have to believe you are the
legitimate ruler.
You cannot compel them. You must win
their hearts and minds.
Okay? And this explains why Charlemagne
would want to be crowned by the Pope
because the Pope did have legitimacy, he
did have authority because the Pope was
the leader of the Catholic Church. Now,
at this time, there were many kings, not
all of them, but there were many kings
in Europe who were of the Catholic
faith.
Okay?
Um so, this is a map of
the major cities of the world
at the time of the fall of the Roman
Empire, okay? As you can see,
most of the cities are located at a
certain latitude.
And to the north, okay, which is where
Europe is, there are not that many major
cities.
All right? So, at the fall of the Roman
Empire, Europe was a divided, weak, and
poor place.
Okay?
All right? So, again,
the Please remember for the rest of the
semester these three factors, right?
Latitude,
you need a temperate climate,
you need um natural boundaries, and you
need a major river.
And this will And this will allow
civilizations to rise and prosper.
The great irony of The great irony here,
of course, and we will learn about this
um later in the semester, is despite its
disadvantages, Europe was still able to
conquer the world.
All right? And it did so because of
these disadvantages. If you think about
it, these disadvantages compel you as a
people, as a culture, to be innovative
to overcome these disadvantages.
All right? And this is something that we
will learn when we get to the
Enlightenment, Renaissance, and uh
Scientific Revolution, which we will do
very quickly.
All right?
Um the other thing about Europe that's
very important is um it was constantly
being invaded. Look, if you look at this
map, you will see that there are a lot
of mountains protecting Egypt,
Mesopotamia, um and Indus Valley and
China, but there are almost none
protecting Europe from the steppes.
As we discussed last semester, the
steppes traditionally has been the most
aggressive
place
um
in human history.
People are always fighting each other
for territory. These are pastoral people
who need land to raise their uh sheep
and cattle.
And so, they're always fighting each
other. So, what happens over time is
these people are pushed further out into
the uh borderlands, okay? They're often
pushed into Europe.
All right? So, remember
about the Yamnaya people, how they
migrated from the steppes to Europe and
basically conquered all of Europe. Well,
this process never really stops.
Okay? So, um
in the time of the Roman Empire, towards
the collapse of the Western Roman
Empire, there's huge migrations
of people from the steppes into Europe.
And they're being pushed out by a new,
more aggressive people called the Huns,
okay? You may have heard of Attila the
Hun. Well, he's of that group. And they
are extremely violent, and they have
made major military innovations that
allow them to outcompete others in the
steppes, which forced these other tribes
and groups into
uh Europe, okay? Which is the only place
they can go.
All right?
Um after the collapse of the Roman
Empire,
um these different groups
start to form their own kingdoms.
And around Germany are the Franks. And
then eventually over time,
um as these groups compete against each
other, the Franks will ultimately defeat
them and expand. Okay? But this is a
process that will take centuries through
multiple kings and through multiple
dynasties. But eventually, um the the
Franks will expand out from Germany and
conquer most of Europe. Not all of
Europe, but they will conquer um most of
Europe. And in the process, what's
interesting for us is they will make
contact
with the once isolated
um Scandinavian countries. Um
the the the Norsemen, okay? They're
called the Norse. We we often refer them
to as Vikings, and we will study them
next class, okay? But now they're
brought
brought into the orbit of this new
Frankish Empire.
Okay?
But again,
becau- And and this is the
Frankish Empire at the time of
Charlemagne, when he creates the Holy
Roman Empire. But again, because
this is not really an empire, it's more
of a confederation, it doesn't really
last much longer after his death. What's
really interesting for us is to remember
that these emperors, they are not
born as emperor. They are elected by
other kings.
So again, you should see this as an
alliance, as a confederacy, where each
king has voting power.
Okay? So, this is not a
hereditary title. This is something that
you are elected to.
Okay?
So, after the death of Charlemagne,
um a couple decades later after his
death, the
empire splits into three.
Okay? And even though um on paper, this
empire does last until the year 1806,
it's a history uh that is extremely
tumultuous.
And most And there are sometimes when
the empire completely disintegrates.
Okay? But they
keep up the pretense of having an empire
because again, in Egypt, what matters is
not territory
or military or resources. What matters
the most is legitimacy.
And the idea of the Holy Roman Empire
gives
uh legitimacy, confers legitimacy,
mainly through the Catholic Church.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
So, we'll be discussing more of this as
we go um into the history of Europe.
But before that, are there any
questions?
I'm sorry. Uh are are are are Are there
any questions?
All right? So, now what I want to
discuss
is why the Catholic Church is able to
confer legitimacy. What gives the
Catholic Church the power
and authority to confer legitimacy
uh to kings and emperors?
Okay? But before I do that,
um are you guys clear about what I just
presented?
You mentioned that Charlemagne was
crowned by
Pope Pope Leo the Third, yes.
Pope Leo the Third.
Oh, well, sorry. Okay, so I I'll I'll
explain, okay? But the Pope is
considered the leader of the church in
Rome.
So, he's a bishop, okay? We call him
Pope because historically, Rome was the
most powerful of the churches.
Okay? So, so so so I'll explain who the
Pope is later on, okay?
So, but does that make sense? Good. Any
more questions
before I
continue? Because right now, what I'll
do is explain how the Catholic Church
became so powerful
in Europe.
So, so like you mentioned that
the um
the kings of like
within the kingdoms of the Frankish
uh kingdoms, like they were elected by
other kings.
Mhm.
So,
these kings were not like
siblings or related?
Okay, that's a good question, okay? So,
um Who are Who are these kings? Well,
most of these kings are actually
uh hereditary, okay? Their fathers were
kings, their grandfathers were kings.
And often related to each other, okay?
But they were in control
of a certain fiefdom.
Right? And you couldn't really conquer
them because they had castles. And they
had And they were like in mountains.
And they were a very aggressive people.
So, you couldn't really conquer them.
So, you needed to um get them to to
agree to make you king. And so, the way
they did that was by having these
elections, where the kings got together,
they're called prince electors, and they
pick the the king. And this is also true
for the Catholic Church, where different
bishops would get together, and they
would elect the Pope, okay? But But I'll
explain this later on, okay?
Does that make sense?
All right.
Okay.
So, um let's go over the history of the
Catholic Church and explain understand
why it became so powerful in Europe
after the collapse of the Roman Empire.
Okay.
First, I want to present to you the
official history of the Catholic Church
as presented by the Catholic Church.
So,
um there was a
man named Jesus who was actually a god.
We we didn't know he was a god, but he
was a god
who came down
from heaven in order to sacrifice
himself in order to free us of our sins
to in order to redeem us, okay?
Now, Jesus had disciples.
There are there are 12 major ones, but
there were others.
And after his death, Jesus reappeared
before them
and told them to spread the gospel, the
good news
that he has freed humanity of their sins
and that he will return to create a
heaven on earth, okay? So, that's the
good news, the gospel. So, these
disciples, they're illiterate peasants.
They go all around the world and they
set up churches in the honor of Jesus,
okay? The these are the first fathers of
the church. And these people are called
bishops,
okay?
So, the bishop is the head of the church
in a certain area.
And the tradition is that the very first
bishop of all the major churches
and there were like five um were
disciples of Jesus. That's where their
authority and legitimacy comes from,
from Jesus himself.
Um as the movement is spreading, Rome
sees them as a threat because Rome
are pagans and Christianity is an
anti-pagan religion. So,
um there's a lot of persecution going
on, but the
Christians are armored by their faith
and their love of Jesus and the miracle
that is god. So, they eventually triumph
and convert all of Rome into
Christianity.
Now, Christianity is the official
religion of Rome and now they have the
power to spread the message to all
people around the world, but especially
the barbarians of Europe and convert
them.
Okay? So, that's the official history
of
the church.
And
there are lots and lots of issues
with this story. I mean, the first uh
issue, the major issue is how is it that
a peasant religion was able to conquer
the Roman Empire?
Um
there were certainly other belief
systems that were much more compelling
than the Christian faith. There's a
Greek system, the philosophy of Plato.
Um paganism paganism itself has many
traditions and as I keep on explaining
to you in this class, culture is
persistent. People do not want to change
their cultures.
So, it's a complete mystery how
Christianity was able to spread and
conquer Europe.
And the explanation if you talk to
Christians, especially the Catholic
Church, is it's a miracle, guys. It's
the power of faith, okay? That's the
explanation. That's it.
Um
Okay? So,
there are lots of issues with this
official story. So, I want to give you
my understanding of the history. I
talked about this last semester and I
want to review it, okay? And apply to
the context of the Roman Empire. All
right.
What's important for us to understand is
during the time of the Roman Empire
the Romans had major conflicts with the
provincials, especially the Jews, okay?
Romans and Jews
did not get along.
In fact, they were often in conflict
with each other.
The Romans were pagan and the Jews were
monotheistic people who only worship
Yahweh.
And they refused to worship the Roman
Emperor, which was demanded of them by
the Romans. Sometimes the Romans were
tolerant and said, "Well, we'll make a
special exception for you Jews." But
sometimes they were extremely violent,
okay? And this led to a series of wars
uh in Judea between the Jews and the
Romans. These were terrible, terrible
wars that killed millions of people,
okay? Three major wars were fought.
Another problem is that
the Jews were spread all around the
Roman Empire. So, this is not a problem
isolated to one poor province
called Judea. This was a problem
throughout the Roman Empire,
okay? So,
um
historians estimate that Jews accounted
for about 10% of the population of the
Roman Empire. That's a lot of people. In
certain cities like Alexandria,
um it was a third of the population.
And there were a couple of riots in
Alex- in Alexandria by the Jews against
Roman rule.
Also, the Jews were at as a whole a
pretty cosmopolitan
people who were well-educated uh and who
were very well-established, who looked
down upon the Romans. The Jews had
respect for the Greeks because the
Greeks had a very uh superior culture.
Jews and Persians got along really well
because Persians are extremely tolerant
people, but Jews really didn't like
Romans. And the Romans really didn't
like the Jews either, okay? There's
there's stories of how
after the wars
um between the Romans and the Jews, Jews
were enslaved and sent to Rome. And the
Romans released the Jews in slavery
because they didn't like Jews, okay? And
Jews became traders and set settled um
in other parts of of the empire. Okay?
So, the Romans and the Jews didn't get
along.
And so, there's this constant conflict
going on.
But there are certain Jews like Paul of
Tarsus.
He was a Roman citizen. He was very
well-established within the empire.
And he got along very well with the
Romans. He really much wanted to be part
of the Roman Empire. And these wars were
badly affecting him and his and his
family and and their friends, okay? So,
there were
a certain segment of the of the Jewish
diaspora who were very much wanted to
assimilate into um Roman into the Roman
Empire.
But their religion, okay? Their religion
which believed that eventually a Messiah
who is a prince from the house of David,
born of the house of David, he will
return and he will lead the Jews to
ultimate victory against the Romans.
That's what the Jews believed as part of
their religion.
And so, this presented a problem for
Paul of Tarsus and other Jews who wanted
to assimilate.
Okay?
When Jesus died,
he became like a rock star within the
Jewish community.
And it
the fact that he died, the way that the
fact that he was crucified, which is a
which is a horrible way to die, um it
basically captured the imagination of
many Jews.
And after his death, there were a lot of
people who started to flock to
uh they were very curious about him. Um
so, they flocked to uh his disciples.
And so, um his brother James
led his movement called the poor of
Jerusalem. Later on, they'd be called
the Ebionites, okay? And these are the
people who will influence the Islamic
religion.
But there were other groups who started
around Jesus around the idea of Jesus as
well. Basically, Jesus was a growing
popularity
um in the Jewish world after his death.
And in Jesus, Paul saw an opportunity to
resolve this conflict between Romans and
Jews.
Remember, the problem for Jews is their
religion believed that a Messiah would
return who would lead them to victory
against the Romans.
And this is a problem
uh because Paul knew that if the Jews
united against the Romans, the Romans
would probably win, okay? So,
Jesus is a solution because Jesus is a
prophet of peace, right? Jesus was
a prophet who preached the importance of
peace, mercy, and forgiveness. Forgive
the Romans for destroying our temple.
Forgive the Romans for persecuting us.
Show mercy because what mattered is not
what happens here, what happen what
matters is what happens in heaven.
All right? So,
Paul of Tarsus, backed by the Roman
state, started this religion
as a way for Jews to practice their
faith without incurring the wrath of the
Roman Empire, without being a threat to
the Roman Empire, okay? Does that make
sense to you guys?
Now, over time as the conflict between
the Romans and Jews became worse and
worse, the Christian movement spread,
okay? And eventually,
to gain legitimacy, they won the
patronage of Roman uh patriarchs, okay?
So, uh you had a certain segment of
elite Jews and a certain segment of
elite Romans
who came together in the Christian
church
uh, to build an alliance.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, in other words, um, the Catholic
church, the beginning of Catholic
church, it was basically basically an
elite social club for Jews and Romans to
get together and to work together.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Now, what's important for us to
understand is there are other Christian
factions during this time, but because
the Catholic church, the beginning the
portal Catholic church, it's backed by
the Roman state, and because of its
organization and its wealth, it was able
to ultimately win out over the other
Christian sects. Okay? Does that make
sense?
All right. Now, over time,
what the Romans recognize is,
"Wow, the Christian church
is great at solving the Jewish problem.
And then they recognize that, oh,
wouldn't be good for solving all our
problems? Okay? Because because
eventually, um, the Jews cease to be the
major problem, and these barbarian
barbarian coming in from the steps and
from the north are the major problem.
And there's just too many of them.
Okay?
So, remember you have all these
um,
barbarians coming in.
What's important to remember about these
barbarians is this is not an invasion,
okay? An invasion.
Often, historians will use the word
barbarian invasion.
They're not invaders. They're migrants.
It's a migration, guys.
What's the difference? Well, if it's if
it's an invasion, these people are
looking to conquer the Roman Empire and
instill upon the empire their world
view, their culture, their religion.
If it's a migration, these people are
looking for better economic
opportunities.
And therefore, they are willing to
conform to your world view, to your
religion.
All right? So, think about the United
States, where on the southern border,
there are millions of people
every year who are trying to get into
the United States. They're not there to
conquer the United States.
They're there to migrate to the United
States and seek a better life. And they
know
that if they are to succeed
in the United States, they must
assimilate.
Okay? And
the best way to assimilate in the United
States, of course, is to go to
university.
Right?
Because once you're part of of the
university, you're now part of the
social elite. Okay? That's the best
thing to do.
But a lot of people don't have the
wealth, the education to go to
university. So, what what they often do
is join the church, okay? The church.
Um,
if you look at
these
hundred thousands, these millions of
Chinese students who have gone to the
United States,
the group that has assimilated the best
are Chinese Christians, right?
These are, um,
Chinese who are either practicing
Christians or they convert to
Christianity when they go to the United
States. Because when they when they're
Christians, there's an immediate social
community for them that welcomes them
and supports them.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right? So,
um,
this is the United States, but this was
true during the late Roman Empire as
well.
Okay? The you have all these barbarians,
they're called barbarians,
and they're coming in,
and they're trying to assimilate. And
the Roman Empire needs to assimilate
them as well. And what they discovered
is the best way to do that is through
the Catholic church.
Right? Because remember, these pay these
these barbarians, they're pagans. They
worship war, they worship violence.
They're problem
in the long term.
But they convert to Christianity, which
is a religion that preaches peace,
mercy, forgiveness,
kindness.
Right? Then
they're bad then they're then they're
easier to manage.
And what happens is
that,
um, a lot do convert. Okay? Now, some of
you may say, "Well, this sounds very
cynical."
Right? These people
are changing their religion,
and they're doing so for their own
material benefit. Okay? What's important
for us to understand is that
if you look at any religion,
if you go to any church,
you will find that the people who most
believe in this religion, who are the
most fanatical about this religion, are
new converts.
Does that make sense?
If you're born into this religion, if
your parents are Christians, you take it
for granted.
Okay? And you are often dubious and
skeptical because children like to rebel
against their parents. But
if you convert to Christianity, if you
do so out of out of your own choice,
well, then you
are fully committed now, okay? And this
is because of a psychological principle
called the sunk
cost fallacy.
To turn to a new religion means to give
up
your community, your traditions, your
history, your sense of identity.
And because because of all this, you are
stuck with this new religion, whether or
not you truly believe it or not. And I
And because of that, because of the sunk
cost fallacy,
uh, because you have you have lost so
much in the process, you are now fully
committed to the religion. You are so
fanatical that you not only convert, but
you want to convert others as well.
Okay? Does that make sense? So, so with
the barbarian invasions, the Catholic
church experiences tremendous growth
because now they are letting in lots of
converts who are fanatical about the new
religion.
All right?
The church is also a mechanism of social
mobility,
um, for the barbarians because
uh, Roman society, it's very,
uh, parochial.
Uh, it's very close-minded. It doesn't
like it doesn't it doesn't like doesn't
like foreigners, okay? But traditionally
in human history, the church and the
military
were the two major mechanisms of social
mobility. If you're an outsider and you
want to rise in society, you either join
the church or you join the military. And
this And this has been true for, uh, in
Europe for hundreds of years. Okay?
The last thing about the church that's
very important is,
um,
in trying to co-opt new people, it
recognizes that it must first co-opt the
elite.
Okay? Now, but barbarians do not they do
not have or most barbarians do not have
a concept of a hereditary elite. Their
leaders are often people who are elected
for the moment.
Okay? So, it's possible to to switch
leaders if the leaders aren't performing
a good job.
What the church does is
in exchange for joining the the the
church, the church can make these
leaders, who are again only temporary,
into a hereditary elite.
Meaning their advantages in social
status will pass on to their children,
which is an extremely,
um,
appealing, um,
deal for these barbarian leaders, okay?
Does that make sense?
All right? So,
as the barbarians keep on migrating to
Rome, the Catholic church is the main
mechanism that absorbs them, okay? Also
the military as well. So, it's the
military and the church of the Roman
Empire that mainly absorbs them.
And this And because of this idea,
the church is a mechanism which allows
you to join the Roman Empire,
the church acquires tremendous
legitimacy and prestige and status.
Okay? Does that make sense for you guys?
All right?
All right.
But in this system,
okay?
Local churches have local autonomy.
Because you're trying to let in local
elites, okay? If you let in local
elites, you have to give them autonomy.
And, um, towards the end of the,
uh, Roman Empire, there are five major
churches
that rule collectively.
Uh, the major church is in Rome, okay?
Again, the leaders,
um, of these churches are called
bishops.
There's Rome, there's Constantinople,
there is, um,
Antioch,
there's Alexandria,
and these are the four major population
centers of the Roman Empire, and then of
course, there is Jerusalem.
And Jerusalem is is part of this five
because of its
uh prestige, right? This is where
Jesus uh died. And this is the This is
where the
uh
Jewish and Christian religions were
born, okay?
So,
um
for most of of this history, these are
the five major churches. And for most of
this history, they're independent of
each other. There are other churches in
other places as well that are also
extremely independent of each other.
Meaning they were allowed to, within the
Christian framework, develop their own
doctrine and practices.
Okay? But, it was understood
the uh primary church was Rome because
Rome was the center, the capital of the
Roman Empire. And because of this, the
bishop here
is called the Pope
in order to distinguish him from the
other bishops.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right.
The problem with this system is that the
capital in 330 switches from Rome over
to Constantinople.
And over time, the Constantinople
church,
because it is now the capital, it wants
to assert its authority
over the other churches.
Mainly through the idea of orthodoxy,
right? Orthodoxy or doctrine.
Remember,
for most of this history, each local
church is free to um create its own
ideology within the Christian framework.
Mainly because um no one's in a position
to enforce doctrine on others.
Now, Constantinople, want because it's a
capital of the empire, it wants to
impose orthodoxy on others.
And this is what leads to the idea of
the Nicene Creed. Remember, the Nicene
Creed is the idea of the Holy Trinity.
And at this time, when the Nicene Creed
is first formulated,
um most people,
most churches, do not buy into the
Nicene Creed. They don't do They do not
buy into the Holy Trinity.
But, Constantinople sees the power of
the Catholic Church as a source of its
legitimacy. Therefore, it will, over the
decades, embark on military expeditions
to enforce the Nicene Creed on all
dissenters. Eventually, the Nicene Creed
will triumph
over other doctrine.
Okay? So,
uh the Catholic Church
is able to build legitimacy and power by
imposing orthodoxy.
But, over time, as we know, the
Byzantine Byzantine Empire will decline
in power and prestige, mainly because
the Byzantine Empire
the military is not as strong as it used
to be.
And at this point, the Constantinople
church is declining, other churches,
especially in Rome,
they want now to assert their local
autonomy.
Okay? So, this created a major
controversy called an
iconoclasm iconoclasm. Iconoclasm just
means that Constantinople believes
that God should not be celebrated in
images.
You cannot paint God. You cannot uh
paint Jesus.
Okay?
And the
church in Rome, the Pope, saw this as an
opportunity to push back because this
was actually a very unpopular decree.
And this created a major conflict
between Rome and Constantinople. And
what this iconoclasm debate shows us is
that Rome wants to
maintain its independence.
Not only does Rome want to maintain its
independence, it wants to regain its
lost authority.
Okay?
And that's why
when Charlemagne comes along,
the church sees Charlemagne as the
perfect opportunity
to reassert its dominance. It's
it's
uh dominance over the idea of
legitimacy, okay?
Right? And so, they work together to
create the idea of the Holy Roman Empire
as a competitor
to the Byzantine Empire
and and as a mechanism in order to
ensure the legitimacy and the prestige
of the Catholic Church in Rome against
that of its competing churches, mainly
in Constantinople, but also in places
like Alexandria, Antioch, and Jerusalem.
All right.
And this will eventually climax in
something called the Great Schism.
The Great Schism.
We'll study this later on. The idea of
the Great Schism, which happens around
1000, all right, is that that these two
churches, Rome and Constantinople,
permanently break off. They refuse to
acknowledge each other.
Before, they would have meetings and
they would share doctrine, but now they
absolutely refuse to talk to each other,
okay? And Rome will become the basis of
the Catholic Church. Catholic means
universal,
which still
is still around today and it which is
believed by about 1 billion people,
okay?
Constantinople becomes the basis of the
Eastern Orthodox Church, the Eastern
Orthodox Church, which is um believed by
about 230 million people, mainly in
Eastern Europe, okay? So, if you're
Western Europe, you're Catholic. If
Sorry, if you're East Eastern Europe,
you're Orthodox. If you're Western
Europe, you're Catholic. Okay, does that
make sense, guys?
And at first, look, there's only one
major doctrinal doctrinal difference
between Rome and Constantinople. Rome
asserts that the Pope is the first among
equals.
Okay? So, the Pope it has the ultimate
authority. The Pope is the true
representative of God on Earth. Everyone
else is
lesser than the Pope. Whereas,
uh the Orthodox Church asserts that all
the churches
are equal to each other. There's no
higher authority.
Okay?
But, later on, because
the
um
the church in Rome will experience the
Protestant Reformation,
um
then their doctrine will radically
diverge over time.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
Any questions about this?
Okay. So, let's summarize, okay? Let's
go back to the year 800 when
Charlemagne, he's in St. Peter's
Basilica,
and he's being crowned
Holy Roman Emperor by Leo the Third.
Why does this happen, okay? And let's
look at at it from the perspective of
Charlemagne
as well as Pope Leo
the Third.
All right.
So, for Charlemagne, it's pure
The three major reasons
are legitimacy,
unity,
and differentiation.
And this has been true for kings
throughout
human history, okay? Why did King David
sponsor the writing of the Bible? For
these three reasons. Why did
Augustus Caesar sponsor the writing of
the Aeneid? For these three reasons,
okay? Legitimacy. I'm the rightful king
because God said so. Unity. We're We're
all
part of the community of God.
Okay? And that's what differentiates
differentiates. We are Christians and
everyone else is pagan or infidel or
heretic.
Differentiation. We are not the
Byzantine Empire, okay?
So, Charlemagne
is trying to create legitimacy, unity,
and differentiation with the Holy Roman
Empire.
Okay?
So,
Pope Leo,
why does he
um
sponsor Charlemagne? Why is he crowning
Charlemagne the Holy Roman Emperor?
Well,
um he's trying to assert his authority,
right?
He's trying to establish the fact that
the Pope is the true representative of
God on
on Earth.
Okay? Second is he's trying
to um
protect himself. So, you guys don't know
this, but
in this world,
there's no central power.
And the Pope is elected by other
bishops.
But, in this process, you'll always have
a faction who refuses to accept the
authority of the Pope. And this will
lead to civil conflict. So, before Pope
Leo
uh made Charlemagne emperor, he was also
almost assassinated by his enemies.
Right? So, by making
um
uh Charlemagne the Holy Roman Emperor,
he's actually appealing to Charlemagne
for military protection against his
enemies. Okay? So, there's a lot of um
politics within the Catholic Church,
which still persists to uh today.
Okay?
And of course,
um
differentiation, okay? Or competition.
Sorry, competition. The idea is that the
Catholic Church is in constant compet-
The Catholic Church in Rome is in
constant conflict with that in
Byzantine.
Both the Byzantine Empire um and the
Catholic Church in Rome are trying to
assert that they are the legitimate
heirs to the Roman Empire.
Okay? And obviously Byzantine has a
better case
than
Rome.
And that's why Pope Leo feels compelled
to create the idea of the Holy Roman
uh Empire.
All right?
What I want to show you also that the
idea
of the Holy Roman Empire comes from
Augustine.
Okay?
One thing that you will learn in this
class
that's very different from other
um
class- his- history class you will take
is the power of ideas.
You're taught usually that it's
economics or power
or kings that move history.
You're taught in this class, and this is
very important, it's it's ideas
that move history. Okay? And let let let
me show you how. Okay, Augustine wrote a
book called City of God,
which is what we read
last semester or parts of it last
semester. We discussed it. Okay? What is
City of God? Well, Augustine, he's
basically um a high leader of the
church. He's Bishop of Hippo, okay?
Which is in northern Africa.
And he has a problem because in year
410,
Rome is sacked.
Okay? This is only a few couple a couple
of decades after Christianity is made
the official religion of the Roman
Empire.
Now Rome is sacked by the Goths by by
barbarians who are pagans.
And so what a lot of people start to
believe is that
the pagan gods are
um enacting revenge vengeance against
Rome
for disavowing them.
In other words, the Christian God is a
false god. The pagan gods are the true
gods. And this is local event
where Rome is sacked.
Um
it's so traumatizing that people start
to believe this. So Augustine feels
compelled to write the City of God to
explain the sack and why Christianity is
a true faith.
In the City of God, Augustine says there
are two there are two cities. There's a
city of man of empire called Rome.
Rome is a place where people pursue
power.
Where
kings try to
uh outdo each other.
And then there's Jerusalem.
Okay? Jerusalem.
Which is the city of God.
And and this is metaphorical. Rome is
temporal. It is in time. It is of Earth.
But Jerusalem is heaven itself.
And in heaven,
it's a spiritual place where people
practice their faith, their devotion to
God.
And that is what we should be pursuing.
Okay?
So Rome is trying to create the end of
history,
meaning that it is trying to create an
eternal peace, right? What is called the
Pax Romana.
The emperors are trying to be
the ultimate emperor of humanity.
But Jerusalem means out of history.
You are taking yourself out of human
affairs because the human affairs don't
really matter. What matters is spiritual
faith.
Because only spiritual faith will will
give you salvation and redemption.
And that's what matters.
Okay?
So our mission
is to create Jerusalem. And that's what
the Catholic Church does. The Catholic
Church
is the City of God.
It's the new Jerusalem.
It's what allows humanity to step out of
history and to celebrate God on Earth.
Okay? And the City of God, in other
words, becomes the basis
of the Holy Roman Empire.
In other words, Charlemagne and Leo work
together work together to create the
Holy Roman Empire
in order to achieve Augustine's vision
of heaven on Earth.
The City of God was it's an intellectual
blueprint for the Holy Roman Empire.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
In fact, what's really interesting is
Charlemagne,
who apparently was illiterate. I'm not
completely sure, but apparently he was
illiterate.
Every day, he had the City of God read
to him.
That's how much he loved City of God.
And he basically made City of God the
official text
of the Holy Roman Empire.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
And that's the power of ideas.
Charlemagne in the City of God had
already
created the intellectual framework for
the Holy Roman Empire
that 400
years later Leo and Charlemagne could
take in order to build the Holy Roman
Empire. Without the City of God, they
could not have imagined
the Holy Roman Empire.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
That's the power of ideas.
You need someone to imagine the idea
before you can actually implement it on
Earth.
All right. So let me conclude
by going back to Voltaire's quotation
that we looked at at the beginning of
class. The Holy Roman Empire was in no
way
holy, Roman, or an empire. And as I
promised you, um
I will show you that this is true, okay?
So let's look at this. Holy
Roman
Empire.
The idea of holy
is that the Catholic Church
is really the power in charge.
But that's just pageantry. That's a
fiction, okay? The entire
Holy Roman Empire, it's a useful
fiction.
Okay?
So the king and the pope
uh
are benefit from pretending
the Catholic Church is in charge in
order to confer legitimacy onto the
king.
Okay? And the king and the
pope benefit from displaying
um an alliance to the people of Europe,
okay? To create a sense of unity.
But this fiction depends on the pope and
the emperor getting along.
And after Charlemagne, what we'll see is
they don't get along.
Because the pope insists on having power
over the emperor. The emperor insists on
having power over the pope. But not only
that, remember the pope
and the emperor are all elected by local
lords, okay? So the pope is in is
elected by the bishops of Western
Europe. The emperor is elected by the
prince electors.
And these people are also extremely
ambitious. They want to be the pope.
They want to be the emperor, okay? So
with the idea with the idea of the Holy
Roman Empire, there's still conflict
going on. There's still wars and
competition going on that will last for
centuries and carry us into
um basically 20th century.
But it all goes underground.
They all hide it. They pretend that
Europe is at peace when really
um it's at war. Okay?
And some of the most
atrocious
gruesome stories will come from this
this medieval period. It's a Game of
Thrones situation, okay? So it's not
holy.
The church pre- Everyone pretends the
church is in charge, but it's not
really.
Okay? Roman.
So the authority of the Catholic Church
comes from the fact that it is the
direct descendant of the Roman Empire.
In fact, the Catholic Church uh goes out
of its way to appear like the Roman
Empire.
Um Latin is the language that the
Catholic Church uses for bureaucracy.
And a lot of
um their practices their cultural
practices are like the Roman.
Okay? Um remember that in the Roman
Empire, it's the Senate that confers
legitimacy onto the emperor.
And in this world, it's the Catholic
Church that confers legitimacy onto the
emperor. So the
um Roman Catholic Church is trying to
present itself as a continuation of the
Roman Senate.
But as we discussed
um in previous classes, what matters is
the culture. And as I explained to you,
the culture of the Romans
died
with the empire.
And it's the the death of this culture
started in year 212 when Roman
citizenship
was given to everyone within the empire,
okay? So the Roman Empire died a long
time ago. The Catholic Church is not
Roman.
Native empire.
Okay? So, the Byzantines were an empire
because they had an imperial bureaucracy
and its own military that can enforce
its will on the provinces.
The Holy Roman Empire was never truly an
empire in the sense that the emperor's
will was absolute. He needed
uh the support
of his allies.
And there were many times throughout
this history when the emperor tried to
enforce his will on the prince electors
of Germany, and so they rebelled against
him.
Because they need to protect his
autonomy.
And this idea
that what matters um
the real powers is uh in these princes
in the local areas, this is what will
give rise to the idea of feudalism
uh in Europe.
Okay? Before
um the kings decide to assert their
authority over everyone.
Okay?
All right.
So, the Holy Roman Empire was a useful
fiction for its time in order to
um present the idea of legitimacy and
unity
um across a divided
uh Europe at war with each other.
Right?
Okay. So, next class we will do the
Vikings.
All right? But before we end, any
questions?
You mentioned that the emperor's
will is not um absolute. Yes. But
instead the powers in in the local
princes. Yes. So, did the princes like
cuz they have power rebelled against the
emperor?
Separate?
They made the empire collapse or
something?
Um
Okay.
That's a really good question. Okay,
what what's the relationship of the
prince electors to the emperor?
Okay.
Um
So,
this is a really interesting question.
Okay? So, let's think about this. If you
are prince elector, you are a local
prince
um
in Europe.
Okay? How do you benefit from the Holy
Roman Empire?
Well, you benefit because
the Holy Roman Empire confers legitimacy
to you as well.
Does that make sense?
Right? Because if you're a local prince,
you also have people who want your
throne. You also need to keep your
people united. And the Catholic Church,
the religion of Catholicism, was an
important mechanism for you to assert
authority
over your people
and to keep you safe from your enemies.
In many ways, the Catholic Church, it's
trying to be the freelance imperial
bureaucracy of Europe, right? There's no
emperor. The emperor has no power.
So, the Catholic Church is trying to be
the imperial bureaucracy where it's
trying to create the culture, the
meta-reality of all Europeans.
Okay? And it does that through its local
churches, right? The priests.
Because if you think about it, um the
people are interacting with the local
priests, not with
bureaucrats.
Right? So, through the priest, you can
collect information on the people, like
how much money they're making so you can
tax them better. And you you can better
control their thoughts, okay? So,
everyone's benefiting from this
relationship.
But it's a delicate balance because the
local princes, even even though they're
benefiting from this relationship, they
still demand autonomy. Right?
And the Catholic Church and the emperor,
they want to assert their central
authority over the local areas. So, so
it's a delicate balance.
Right?
Okay. Great question, though. Does Does
that make sense to you, Echo? Yeah. All
right, great. Any more questions?
Okay, great. So, um
next class we will do the Vikings, which
will be a lot of fun.